[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros en
france 24 en 5 minutos con hoy saludamos
a carlos vargas thames jefe de la unidad
de desarrollo y docente de la oficina
regional de educación para américa
latina y el caribe de la unesco gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
es que dicha organización la unesco
presentó un informe este año sobre la
inclusión en la educación de américa
latina y el caribe llamado todos y todas
sin excepción le pregunto entonces señor
vargas cómo estaban trabajando para que
esta inclusión se haga real en una
región tan desigual como lo es américa
latina y el caribe
bueno muchas gracias bueno primero decir
que el informe muestra como la
desigualdad social de los países de la
región se refleja en sus sistemas
educativos y que la diversidad es
concebida más como un problema que como
una virtud o como un tesoro que
viviésemos cultivar el informe aborda y
da cuenta tanto de los esfuerzos de los
países por transitar hacia sistemas
educativos más inclusivos aunque también
advierte la persistencia de algunos
desafíos importantes entonces en
términos digamos como de logros podemos
ver un progreso en las leyes en las
leyes de educación en particular que
hacen alusión a la inclusión aunque
solamente un porcentaje de ellas lo hace
a la inclusión en general es decir de
los grupos que han quedado atrás que han
sido históricamente marginados del
derecho a la educación no estamos
hablando de las mujeres de la diversidad
sexual la población en situación de
pobreza residentes de áreas rurales o
nación migrantes
ahora le pregunto cuál es la
colaboración que tienen ustedes con los
diferentes gobiernos locales para poder
lograr esta verdadera inclusión
bueno en el caso de este reporte por
ejemplo lo que hace es llenar un vacío
en términos de educación del de datos
acerca de la desigualdad es importante
enseñando un poco las máximas del
objetivo de desarrollo sostenible 4 que
es el compromiso internacional por
garantizar la equidad la inclusión y la
calidad en educación en términos de
estos 22 elementos equidad e inclusión
hay poca información los sistemas de
seguimiento de información de los
sistemas educativos no capturan las
necesidades de estos grupos vulnerables
como la discapacidad la población por
ejemplo en citas relación de libertad
así que producimos información para la
toma de decisiones y también promovemos
el diálogo político es decir ver cuáles
son algunos buenos ejemplos para poder
seguir hacia la inclusión de estos
grupos señor vargas cuáles son los retos
particulares para el acceso y la
inclusión a la educación en las zonas
rurales
en las zonas rurales por ejemplo la
pandemia desveló la necesidad de tener
mayores elementos de conectividad por
ejemplo ahora a partir del cobi 19 vimos
cómo los países montaron plataformas
educativas pero éstas no eran accesibles
en el caso de una gran mayoría de la
población real menos del 12 por ciento
según cifras de la cepal tiene acceso a
internet en el hogar en las zonas
rurales sin embargo hemos visto también
otros formatos educativos como las
bibliotecas itinerantes como también la
entrega de materiales las radios
comunitarias digamos son distintas
maneras y creo que una de las respuestas
de este informe es cómo diversificamos
los formatos para adaptar la educación a
las personas y no al revés así es ya
para finalizar esta entrevista le
pregunto cuál es el impacto a largo
plazo de estas desigualdades
bueno el impacto básicamente tiene que
ver con la reproducción de estas
desigualdades
y porque con ellas la reproducción
social de la pobreza y de la de la
inequidad particularmente al verse
excluidas y excluidos de la educación
los grupos más marginados no solamente
reproducen la pobreza sino que también
reproducen temas fundamentales para la
región como la ruptura de la cuestión
social es decir la desigualdad el
distanciamiento el ver la diferencia
como un como un error o como un fallo
más que como una riqueza es algo que se
reproduce también en las en las
relaciones sociales
entonces temas como la violencia por
ejemplo la violencia de género la
discriminación el racismo temas que se
pueden engendrar o se pueden desmantelar
a partir de la educación que esa es
nuestra apuesta profesor vargas gracias
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en esta entrevista aquí en
france 24 en 5 minutos con usted también
gracias por continuar con nosotros
siempre conectados a nuestra pantalla
[Música]